you've got people who love trump and
trump can do no wrong yeah there's a
there's a decent amount of them but
not if you took the and they're clowney
too for sure
yeah so here's the point if you take
trump's die hard trump can do no wrong
individuals
and you put them in a room next to the
trump derangement syndrome
it's 10 to one the trump derangement
syndrome grossly outnumber the trump die
hard you know
phonetics yeah so i you know i often ask
this question and especially on this
show
how do we know that we're not in the in
the wrong
in the wrong side of history or in the
paranoid bubble well i'll tell you this
the side of history is really dependent
upon the winners i guess yeah so
for all we know the communists win and
then we're the bad guys like you know
maybe that's what happens
but i can tell you man there's there's a
couple ways to determine that
we are on the correct side of things at
least in our views and the first one i
mentioned the other day is
i can say i condemn white supremacy and
i condemn antifa
there's zero problems saying extremists
who engage in violence for whatever
reason are bad
i think we've got extremist white
supremacists to engage in very dramatic
and horrifying acts of terror
and we have terrorism coming from antifa
it's all bad there you go
the left these leftists can't say it at
all they can't say anti-foot bad they
can't do it
but i'll tell you what else i can say
this donald trump
has led us to a really great economy
donald trump's also an arrogant
boastful like loudmouth you know i can
say
donald trump's peace agreements are
historical and amazing and i can say
donald trump saying we need retribution
and that the feds went in and just
killed the guy because they didn't want
to arrest him that's insane
the fact that i can easily be like
that's good that's bad shows that we're
like
we are calm and rational and considering
what's before us yeah and the people
with trump anxiety disorder
are not thinking clearly they're they're
not but what about this
george washington was a violent
terrorist
well i mean i don't even think the
british view him that way yeah he was
literally deemed a terrorist by king
george i've i've talked to my friends
who are british and they say they don't
it's it's like you got what i was told
is you got to understand tim that is a
blip in our history that didn't even
last
because they didn't they didn't win the
no but george washington's terrorist
organization won
pretty great organization i dare say
liberal liberal terrorist organization
freedom and individuality you know if
you talk to um
i'm you know carl from benjamin um and
so like i watch
his stuff a lot and i heard him talk
about
the united states as being the
end result of what the english were
trying to do
and he's just trying to take credit for
the cool stuff yeah
he might be english would be the first
to ban slavery is the english
uh i don't know if they think that but i
i know that they before
us yeah they did it before us um and i'm
thinking more
um along the lines of of the
the the way that individuals
are looked at as opposed to the way that
the monarchy was looked at in england
the
so the idea is that the english the
ideas that were like laid out in the
magna carta and and laid out
um that really kind of got their start
but in england
don't they still have a house of lords
uh where their political powers derived
from their land ownership centuries ago
they've inherited
i don't know i don't know enough about
it to to criticize
a lot but it does sound like a house of
clown cards right yeah
so uh no i can't i could um i i get i
get it i think
i think a lot of these ideas um made
their way over here and then
something really interesting that
happened i guess is distance from the
crown
yeah people had no allegiance something
they didn't know about
i mean you were born here yeah and you
grew up here you're like i don't know no
king
yeah i don't know anything about that
and so people were like stop telling me
what to do
yeah especially when you consider like
in in if you were in england or whatever
you're in london it's a very dense
populated area yeah
you grew up in the in the colonies or
whatever you're in wilderness
it's wilderness as far as i can see you
can do whatever you want you're like
walking through the woods
like you know take a dump wherever and
like you're shooting your musket and
stuff and you're yelling and singing
you're you go to back to england to go
to london and you've got rules you can't
do that same is true for here in the u.s
you live in new york
you can't play loud music you've got the
medal no you can fire a gun you know
into the hillside or whatever
i uh i am familiar with that so you you
have a bunch of people it's really
fascinating because i was thinking about
the urban versus rural debates that we
have in the country this is before like
the internet era you know like maybe the
2000s
and i was like there really is an
interesting thing here where you see
like the urban cities
are very restrictive and the rural
conservatives are much more about
freedom and openness because they have
more space to kind of be free
and it's similar in in many ways to like
what made people want to leave
these these densely populated areas in
europe and then come to the new world
and find something new
sanders was onto something when he was
talking about the uh assault weapons ban
and he's like
seriously that's he's like we don't have
that problem in vermont because we're a
rural exactly
state and and so it's not a thing and
you know as much as i'm not really i was
never really a pro bernie sanders guy i
was definitely much more of a ron paul
guy
um but he definitely had
you know he had some points you know
sanders has had some
some yeah but he's sold out well yes he
did
i mean look when he he laid down and
kissed the ring which he should have
never done and i i've again talking to
some of my
more left-leaning friends that i'll be
like you know look sanders was made
a clown by hillary clinton and having to
give up the mic to those
protesters on his own stage and that was
it was just like he's he's
a uh a wuss he's not gonna he can't be
president i'm trying to be
with i'm trying to doing it i'm doing it
um you know and then people will be well
you know they make the excuses and
and i just i'm just like ron paul never
sold out
what what and and people like oh you
know i
i know you're you're blah blah blah ron
paul and dada but it's true like but but
now
paul caught so much crap from the from
the
from everybody all the time dr no
constantly
yeah the only guy or one of him and one
other guy him and kucinich didn't voted
no on something that everybody else
voted
yeah that's why i liked kucinich back in
the day yeah and you know and the other
thing ron paul did is he he
self-replicated a younger version of
himself
who's also known everything random rant
is awesome i'm a big fan of rand paul as
well
there's like the no vote i've i there's
very few politicians i will outright be
like i really like that politician yeah
and it's basically just rand paul
because there's other politicians i can
say that i like they've done this i'd
like to have done that like uh rokhana
for instance is a democrat who called
out pelosi because she won't sign the
stimulus deal
and i think he's absolutely right yeah i
think at this point
the the senate is is republican trump
the presidency is republican if you want
to get this signed and done you don't
have the leverage to sit there and
scream you just
get the people the checks they need and
even you recognize that yeah but pelosi
is like oh no
i i won't give trump the orange man or
he can't win oh yeah
it boggles the mind um
it's unfortunate that she has the cover
that she has
because most people don't pay very close
attention
i don't i don't feel like they do and i
feel like that's what she's relying on
because
if the average person knew that
the democrats were holding up a stimulus
bill
that they were they were the the reason
that we couldn't get something passed to
you know to provide relief for the
american people i think that that it
would have a significant effect on their
attitude cnn called her out
did they really wolf blitzer good said
your colleagues want you to agree to
this
and she goes well we represent these
people and and
like they were both trying to get the
last word it was oh yes okay
yes i did hear that all right i heard i
didn't i didn't know exactly what the
context was but i heard the back
the exchange and the crazy thing to me
is you've normally got these lefties who
defend the media and they're like trump
is wrong for something the media now i'm
seeing all of these progressives i know
cnn is trash they're they're they don't
understand
it's trump's fault and i'm like okay
yeah fake news huh
that's what they're saying about the new
york post they've spent they've spent
cnn has
has spent three and a half or four years
trying to
do everything they can to discredit
donald trump like
four years of of you know what program
is coming up it's the orange man badge
show
with with brian selter followed by the
orange man bad show
with chris cuomo followed by fareed
zakaria and why the orange man is really
bad and fat and unhealthy
you know like so here's here's the thing
too it's like
um maybe there is a bias on my part
i can i just praised ro khanna because
he also he also voted in in line with
trump to pull withdraw our troops from
from
afghanistan yeah get out and i'm like
this guy sounds pretty good he's also
voted on some things i think are kind of
bad and i'm like so i don't agree this
guy across the board but hey man
if you're if you're anti-interventionist
you want to get our troops back and
you're you're willing to compromise and
i'll i will give you praise and respect
you turn on cnn
no there's not a kind word for trump at
any point
and they do this they they do this foe
recognizing trump that's not real
like well we understand the president
but
yeah but the thing the thing that like
you you
mentioned earlier like rand paul um
and i again i agree totally rand paul
i'm a big fan
you can look at rand paul and see the
way that people like uh
tony poznanski he's a twitter guy he's a
he's a holly back guy
hollerback yeah he's one of those guys
he's one of those hollerback girls
on on the internet and he just hates on
rand paul and it's like
look i get that you don't like some of
the policies
but really what you're hating on is this
narrative that's been built about rand
paul because rand paul
is the guy that came up with the justice
for brianna taylor bill
no one knows that and no exactly nobody
knew no one is aware
they were yelling at him in the streets
say her name i drafted the bill
it's like people don't know what
policies
he would be for or against they don't
know anything about his
his uh philosophy of what how he how he
thinks that the government should be
organized and what
what the role of the senate in congress
is and blah blah they just go and
they say oh rand paul he's that guy that
tony poznan the guy that
that sells baseball cards on twitter
doesn't like
like that it's it's again i mean
my shirt says everything is stupid and
nothing matters and it's really
true it really there's like kind of faux
cyrillic
yeah exactly yeah there we go um and
that that's that's
i mean that's kind of a catchphrase that
i've i've kind of adopted because
there's just so
much stupidity where people just don't
know why they're upset or why they're
angry why they don't like this person or
that person or whatever you know i don't
wanna i don't wanna name any of these
lefty channels
so just so you guys know cause i don't
wanna promote them or even drag them i
don't want people going
but it's like when when there are people
who try to make videos criticizing me
and it's clear they've never actually
watched any of my videos
it's it's that's that's the problem it's
you have people who have found a way to
monetize
tribalist rage and then they say things
that aren't true or don't make sense but
it doesn't matter as long as it satiates
that that that tribalist lust
for attacking the other so you'll get a
lot of these channels on youtube
both left and right that are like this
youtuber is dumb no that youtuber is
dumb
and i'm like i wonder if you guys
actually watch each other's content they
don't they probably don't
you know clips maybe clips that are sent
them from from
and the clips are going to be out of
context and it's like you could
that's why i'm very careful when i like
i was quoting um
prince harry when he made yeah
this is what prince harry prince harry
said
he says this yeah he thinks according to
prince harry that this world
prince harry says was made according to
prince harry you gotta do it that way
because they're gonna cut it and they're
gonna be like look dude
there was one where i was uh
paraphrasing some racist stuff that he
said
okay we gotta we gotta say it now so
people understand the context
but prince harry said said that this
world was created by
princess according to prince harry white
people and then he went on to say
uh it was created by them for according
to prince harry white people
can you believe that full quote it's
amazing without the four prince harry's
in between but i do that because you
know they're going to try and pull it
and they don't care
we should also point out he's not a
prince anymore someone i think i
received some comments like he's not a
prince anymore guys yeah he lost his
time
so now he's just hairy uh good whatever
he's just a guy
well then what do i care what some guy
thinks so exactly he's just a guy he's
just a guy that's holding megan's purse
oh gosh at this point that's kind of the
deal man
she wants to she's just like she's like
harry if you want to get any tonight you
better get up there and you better say
these things
dude she made him get rid of his guns
the man was a hunter and he was a
soldier and his wife
let him get rid of his guns it was a
status crazy story man
i was in i was in a relationship with
someone that i really really really
cared about and i wasn't about to move
somewhere where i wouldn't have
no so it's that's that's not a healthy
relationship no
you can't you can't do that because she
clearly doesn't respect him at all
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you